so today we're asking the question
it's her body her choice right we have
the right not to be mothers right 100
yeah so
yeah so i was about to say i've got a
strong opinion about it because i don't
really want kids and i can just imagine
like how
horrible it would be if you don't have a
choice to
like do you know like get rid of
the baby so the question is should men
have the right then not to be fathers
so if a woman gets pregnant and he says
i i want to renounce playing child
support
would you support that so he can sign
off all of his rights and leave it with
the mother
yeah because we get the right to get rid
of the kid if we want shouldn't he have
the same right in the name of like
equality that's a tough one because i
guess it that would be first um because
it's the same as the mum giving up the
child but then it's not really in their
body so i don't know how different it is
really so um because the problem we're
having is it incentivizes women to get
kids off of rich guys so for example the
nba has issued statements telling
players to flush their condoms because
girls will steal them because they know
if they get a kid off of them
they're entitled to child support for 18
years i always say okay i didn't know
that yeah
and even drake i don't know if you heard
about when he put hot sauce in his
condom i don't know yeah the girl tried
to sue him over it [ __ ]
that's crazy actually yeah so it's like
when we're seeing things like that it
begs the question like should men have
the right not to be a father too and you
would say yeah 100 to be honest yeah
okay well we agree then thanks for
stopping
a man a man who abandons his child as a
deadbeat dad correct
um not really there are like
do you want me to elaborate there there
are like many
conditions that
allow for
for that to be to be possible and
morally permissible in in most cases um
it's to do with uh ties in a lot with
poverty
um but you know
i don't know if the label of debbie that
dad is like all-encompassing i think
selective cases maybe sorry i meant
society calls them a deadbeat dad
correct 100 i think that's something
that's yeah pretty well known it's
so if a mother abandons her child why
don't and why do we call it the right to
choose well i don't really see that as
abandonment because obviously when when
we're talking about the idea of a
deadbeat dad uh we're talking about a
child that's uh that's that's
you know uh been been born raised by a
single mother in in that instance um but
a woman abandoning her child um
that that's not referred to as as the
right to choose that's that they're
different things if a woman left their
child after their child was born
then if if they're not being called out
then you can you can make that argument
what about adoption what what about
adoption that's also the right to choose
right so i'm saying like even if a woman
gives up her child we don't call her a
deadbeat mom
even after it's born oh see sure sure
okay yeah so i'm asking why do you think
that is why do i think that is um
possibly because i think that there
needs to be
more leniency
uh on the side of uh of women in in that
regard because i think that uh
women who have to give their children up
for adoption uh it is very different
circumstances in the majority of cases
from a man uh uh you know uh leaving the
leaving the family home or or divorcing
or separating well so i'm not why is it
different because i mean it could it
doesn't mean they were together if you
get pregnant right it just means they
were sleeping together so how is it
different if a man doesn't want to be a
father than if a woman doesn't want to
be a mother
because to me it's like it's the same
thing
sure okay and and i'll i'll i'll follow
that line of reasoning then so let's say
it is the same thing
what what what does that insinuate for
you
what does insinuate what do you mean
so so you're saying that uh you think it
is the same thing you think that they
are equivalencies
so uh what what does that insinuate for
you what what does that lead on to is do
you see that as a big problem that they
are viewed the same or do you see that
as the right thing do you see that as
not not very common that they're viewed
the same well i think women are given
passes for doing the same thing that men
do
there's a reason why women are given
passes in areas where men where men
don't why because of a pre-pre-existing
privilege that men have in in the
majority of cases
in life in society
how do men have
a privilege how do men have privilege
when they're the majority of suicides
when they do the majority of hard jobs
they have to fight in wars
okay so so okay
i i think that if what you're asking and
what we're gonna have to talk about is
where men have privileges then we're not
gonna be able to have this argument with
this this debate we're not gonna be able
to talk about this because we're just
simply not on the same level of
understanding about society as a whole
if you're unable to understand that men
have privilege in the majority of cases
and that there is an underlying
privilege that all men have by nature of
a patriarchy well i'm asking like what
what stats do you have to back that up
right so so i would say i would say like
men men also make up the majority of
homeless
so so how can you say that women have an
easier life
okay okay so what i just want to know
what what privilege are you talking
about okay
i'll talk about uh what i mean by
privilege i'm talking about um an
underlying uh uh
societal um condition that allows for
for men to to be paid more okay okay uh
allows for for men to to you know and
you know we talk about uh heinous crimes
uh and that's something that because of
the condition of men you see i i believe
that it's because of our economic state
okay men are more likely to be victims
of a violent crime than women hey but
not a sexual violent crime
not not well i think it goes under
reported to be honest
both go under-reported don't they
because women also don't report uh at
the same level uh that they the the uh
is the potential of the amount of women
who've been abused that goes under
reported as well doesn't it
uh
i don't know i don't think i actually
might have a stat for that which is the
uh um only one in three sexual assaults
are reported to the police only well
okay so the stat that's often referred
to is that one of is it one of four or
one in three women or victims of sexual
assault so they actually would include
if a woman is drunk and has sex
in that stat so no that's what i'm
saying so that they they throw that stat
around a lot and it's not actually
accurate i'm gonna uh i've got my
friends here from from sweden i'm gonna
put an end to this because uh and the
reason i'm gonna say that okay
is that as i've said if you're unable to
understand the the the means at which
men are privileged in society over women
you're telling me i'm oppressed
sorry are you telling me i'm oppressed
sorry what do you you're explaining my
oppression to me do you feel oppressed
no
okay well then it's not an issue for you
is it but there are many women who do
there's a lot of women that don't are we
talking globally here
are we talking what do you mean by that
well i know that i'm talking about the
western world we're in england us
okay why why why don't we take it global
why not
because we're in the uk and i'm from the
us okay so in the u.s do you feel that
uh you you have um the same uh
allowances of privilege than men i think
i have more privilege than most men
so so the statement means right
women we have the right if we get
pregnant we have the right not to be
mothers right yeah should men then in
the name of equality have the right not
to be fathers their wallet their choice
they can sign off on child support why
no because if you had sex with a woman
you fully know well that one of the
consequences is that you will fully like
pregnant her and you have a child so you
have to look after child as that's your
responsibility your sperm your
responsibility okay you can't run away
from that okay i don't understand why
people in their mind think it's all
right to run away from the child that's
a child you're leaving them with so much
trauma having no like dad and everything
that will leave them with severe like
ideas of how they think about men
because